if the radical left come up with a good
solution to this issue i will happily
back it if the right do i will happily
back it i care about solving the problem
and to me it seems just ridiculous that
we go oh but conservatives and you know
why why can't we just leave this to
people who actually know what they're
doing
have we lost the ability to do that
entirely
[Music]
sure feels like that
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today i am
delighted to say is the one and only
michael schallenberger who's here to
talk about the second of a trilogy of
books this one is called san francisco
and it's about the way progressives are
in cities michael welcome to
trigonometry
thanks so much for having me on guys i'm
a huge fan well we are huge fans of
yours as well so we really appreciate
you finding the time to talk to us let's
get straight into it before we do though
tell everybody a little bit about who
are you how are you where you are what
has been your journey through life
because you've done a lot of stuff
you've run for governor in california
you've written a ton of books you've
done all sorts of stuff so give us give
our audience a little flavor of what
you've been up to
sure so i am
a
27-year resident of california i'm 50
i'm lifelong
liberal activist i really came out of
the radical left
i'm a now a journalist and an author i
have a small research organization in
berkeley california
best known for my work on the
environment i had a book on the
environment come out last year called
apocalypse never why environmental
alarmism hurts us all i'm a big advocate
of nuclear energy have been for 10 years
been helping to build a pro-nuclear
movement around the world and but i've
also i'm also someone that's been very
concerned about the growing homeless
problem
where i live in california it's
something i've always been concerned
about
have always understood is a problem of
addiction mental illness also expensive
housing plays a role
and
wanted to understand more about what was
happening
to
my
city state and country
and and therefore did this book san
francisco which came out last
month and a very good book it is and
michael i i i imagine you being a very
smart and well researched man you'll be
aware of this but it's not just
california it's not just san francisco
the one thing that always horrified
francis and i when we used to walk
around london before the pandemic was
there's tents everywhere people on the
streets everywhere there's you know you
go to trafalgar square supposedly one of
the greatest tourist attractions in
london and often you'll see a massive
queue of people just queuing up to be
served hot food in the middle of winter
you know it seems to be happening all
over the western world
why are so many people now living on the
streets of our cities
yeah the big issue is untreated mental
illness and addiction everywhere that's
true for europe as much as the united
states there are some migrants that are
that constitute the european homeless
population there's obviously always been
roma
that have also been part of the european
homeless population but the big
increases that you're seeing the people
that look like they're drug addicts
um
dirty clothing you know been on the
streets for a long time
those are folks suffering from serious
menta mental untreated mental illness or
addiction and some we can get to the
difference some people think that
there's no difference
that's a big cause of the increase and
the major one of the major factors for
it is that uh hard drugs became a lot
less a lot less expensive the first
so-called homeless crisis in the 80s was
really driven by cheap crack
uh cocaine was
a luxury drug for affluent people until
they were able to kind of synthesize it
chemically and make it a shorter high
cheaper high
as crack and then we had a heroin shows
up more in the late 80s early 1990s in
europe and the united states
and now we're dealing with successive
waves of cheaper methamphetamine cheap
heroin and and now fentanyl which is 50
times more potent than heroin and is
causing
a huge amount of drug deaths
you know there is huge differences
scotland has a worse drug problem than
the united states right now
but the netherlands
has a fraction of the deaths that we
have in the united states i think it's
somewhere around
um
you know two or three percent of the
death toll that we have
so san francisco argues that this is a
totally solvable problem but we have to
first recognize that we're dealing with
a problem of addiction and untreated
mental illness
and has mental illness increased in in
recent years uh you know people might i
think more people feel that they have
mental illness now is that borne out by
the statistics are more people actually
mentally ill
that's a very interesting question and
even the way you asked is very very
interesting
so one of the first things that you when
you realize when you understand the
history of mental illness is that the
question of what mental illness is
is a huge question there's a lot of
disciplines where there's debates around
the existence of a central category like
in anthropology it's not clear what
culture is exactly but mental illness
has always been contested there's always
definitely been people that felt like
so-called mentally ill people are not
really mentally ill they might even be
spiritually superior
they might be what we now politically
correct called neuroatypical
there's other people that have always
felt there's clearly a genetic component
to this or a genetic component that's
clearly released in adolescence the most
distinctive version of it is
schizophrenia but interestingly enough
you know british doc british psych
there's a famous study of british
psychiatrists and american psychiatrists
diagnosing the same people but as
i think the brits
would label things more likely as
bipolar disorder
and american psychiatrists as
schizophrenia so the very question of
what mental illness is has come under
question
then in the post-war era particularly in
the 60s a bunch of radical
uh politically radical
anti-psychiatrists
the most famous whom famous of whom is
the french historian michel foucault
really argued that mental illness was
socially constructed as a way to control
different people
and that really it was just a way to
sort of oppress people but also maintain
the fiction of rationality maintain the
fiction of enlightenment reason
and that was really the big prey for
michel foucault
was really taking on this whole history
of particularly cartesian or kantian
enlightenment rationality though in some
ways foucault was a kantian
but that was there was a broader agenda
there that then influenced how we see
mental illness
so now i think constantine i may have
already digressed too far from your
original question
am i going where you want me to go or
did you have no no no well actually i
mean the pro the problem we have is we
we are keen to sort of spend less time
time talking about wokeness but wherever
every rock we lift michelle foucault
pops out
so
i don't really know where to go with
that but i guess
the the basic point is
are we seeing an increase in people who
are mentally ill okay are we seeing
fewer mentally ill people being kept in
facilities where they're being you know
kept from
just living on the street where they're
not you know that was my basic question
and francis has a ton of questions for
you as well okay well let me get to the
first so the first is that there is
basic agreement i would say there's
pretty broad agreement among experts and
even probably policymakers and activists
that serious mental illness is a
separate category and serious mental
illness would include
schizophrenia
bipolar disorder
um
depression
uh being somewhat distinctive although
there's even differences of opinion
about that from bipolar disorder um that
those can be diagnosable because they're
just in a really extreme state
then there's sort of everyday anxiety
and depression that that i think a lot
of us have if i don't exercise enough i
get anxious and depressed for example
and i need to do aerobic exercise in
particular to feel really at my best
psychologically
um do i have a mental illness
i'm sure somebody could argue that i do
um that's not what i would use
i think that there's a there's some
amount of us a lot of us that i think
that needs there's good evidence you
know the runner's high is real that was
a study a few years ago um but i think
there's evidence that a lot of us
benefit from physical activity at a
mental level
and i think there's a lot of evidence
that we're not getting that um and that
also there's been big changes to the
western diet in particular that have
been quite negative um
in apocalypse never i reviewed the
evidence showing that
that high levels of carbohydrate
consumption a high level of protein
consumption even all foods obviously has
negative physical effects but also
potentially mental health effects
and now we're seeing that social media i
think jonathan height has established
conclusively that social media is having
we know it is facebook has acknowledged
it having uh impacts on if you want to
call it mental illness you know i
sometimes worry i think there is reason
to be concerned about
overly pathologizing
you know some amount of you know anxiety
and depression
i think is actually normal and healthy
you know what i mean so that's the other
part of it is that
it's okay to have moods you know and um
and so so there's a there's a kind of a
left-wing critique or a libertarian
critique of psychiatry and psychology
which kind of goes the goal here should
not be to create passionless people
um or to or to get rid of sadness that
would be pointless but i do think it's
fair to say and i think it even
accelerated significantly more in the
pandemic i mean one of the many things
that the one of the many existing trends
that the pandemic
intensified i think is
greater mental illness or psychological
disorders anxiety depression
i think those things clearly have been
increasing for decades
arguably for even
longer if you kind of go these are
really problems that emerge as you move
from the farm to the city with
urbanization
so yeah i would say there's a long-term
trend towards rising
mental illness and other sort of mental
disorders and that's been intensified
even more so in the recent decades as
we've
um you know you know
moved increasingly to a digital world
from a real world
we see declining sex among young people
uh we see a lot of declining risk taking
which is a real problem similarly
jonathan hate
so yeah i mean i do think we we are
seeing an increase in that in some and
to some extent that explains some amount
of the increase of of addiction and
overdose
michael
in the 1980s in this country you
probably know this uh margaret thatcher
one of her policies was closing down a
lot of mental health hospitals in this
country um putting in what is called
care in the community and essentially
leaving the a lot of these people to
fend for themselves has that been a
major cause of what we're now seeing
for sure it has and the united states is
at an even more extreme level than
britain but um europe did a much better
job than i think both the uk and the
united states in terms of dealing with
the seriously mentally ill which are
constitute a significant amount of the
people on the streets
basically the simple way to think of it
is that we had a period in the 19th
century when progressive reformers got
mentally ill people out of the dungeons
in basements out of barns where they
were being chained up
mentally seriously mentally ill people
were killed a lot in the past
very difficult people to deal with
people having delusions
um including delusions of grandeur or
what we call lack of insight now which
is this phenomena where you know crazy
you know people that are insane mentally
ill you know think that they're having
conversations with aliens or the cia and
that they have some inside view of the
secret plot to run the world
and that everybody else is is as crazy
or not and those are very difficult
people in general because the they're
because it's part of mental illness
so yeah but nowadays michael we give
them a youtube channel
to get on with it
[Music]
i was just saying yeah exactly um
so
um yeah we all podcast um so yeah i mean
so there was then a backlash then
basically what happens you go through
the great depression you go through
world war ii
in the united states really around the
western world and there's a lot of
mistreatment of people in these
hospitals these mental hospitals these
mental institutions bedlam of course
being the most famous
of bethlehem and uh in britain you know
that these
hospitals just were understaffed
you know the societies didn't take care
of them because it's a difficult
population families with mentally ill
family members often don't properly take
care of their own family members
because they're so difficult
so then we overreacted and there was a
lot of utopianism in terms of how we
could help
uh integrate people into the community
in some places that they did a better
job than others they did a better job in
in netherlands than they did in britain
and they did a better job in britain
than they did in the united states
and this was also politicized and so
there was a basically the radical left
was using mentally ill people as
pawns in
pursuing a utopian view that the
mentally ill should be
roaming free and that they're they
should be completely integrated i mean
there's
the most uh i thought there's a movie
called minari that won a bunch of awards
the united states i think a couple years
ago about a korean family that oak that
starts a small farm in the south in the
united states in like the 1980s
and there's a character he's a farm
laborer who clearly suffers some from
some kind of mental illness because he
has delusions
and
it's a sweet
portrayal of a well-integrated mentally
ill person into a family's life in a
community
that's very difficult to do and very
very inarguably impossible to do at the
mass level at the urban cityscape level
and so yes in answer to your question
that's been a big part of it and when
those folks discover hard drugs which
make everybody's problems disappear for
you know
two to six hours
it's really hard then you have addiction
and mental illness and that's a big part
of the
of the so-called homeless population
hi francis do you have your own business
no what do you think trigonometry is an
opportunity for me to annoy people and
shout catch phrases birds love it
one two three 4 5 6 7 8 9 10.
well if you do run your own company
you'll know how important branding is to
have a successful business that's why
you should work with the older files
every project is carefully considered
and tailored to ensure your brand is
consistent and memorable to everyone it
reaches most big city agencies are going
to cost you an arm and a leg just so
they can pay their overhead costs the
older files work remotely so you don't
have to worry about being overcharged
not only that they're a one-stop shop
for all your branding needs including
brand development online ad design email
design web design print design motion
graphics and more they do design guys
visit the older files dot com forward
slash triggered and fill out the project
request form to get 10 off your first
project and a free consultation that's
the order files dot com slash triggered
and get 10 off your first project and
free consultation
and it's also just as you touched on
there if we had
communities which had families and there
were core family structures and the
family was much more stable then
people would be would be more able to
look after a family member who wasn't
particularly well they'd be more able to
give them support but because we've all
been so atomized now it just seems more
of these people unfortunately just fall
through the cracks in society
that's right and
so obviously one one approach
i think one might call the conservative
approach you know would be like you just
have to emphasize the need for families
communities and private charity
and that interestingly enough was the
position taken by the radical left
in relationship to mental illness in the
60s
others other countries
netherlands france japan
they're dealing with
mentally ill people what just became
more institutionalized they
they did do a fair amount of
de-institutionalization like
like britain and the united states did
in the 19 after world war ii and really
up through the 70s
but not as much
and so my view is that we have to be
pretty realistic and
while i do think i'm a huge as
especially as i get older and my kids
get older i'm just i really
i appreciate family more than ever
i am very sympathetic to the idea that
there's a lot of functions that can only
be done by the family and can't be done
by governments
at the same time
the fact of the matter is that family
members can't deal with their
schizophrenic you know or even you know
severely depressed family members
particularly if they become addicts
and that that's going to end up being
the role of the government and just
trying to kind of wave our hands and say
let's hope the private charity takes
care of it
has has obviously failed otherwise we
wouldn't have so many people on the
street
but we don't seem to be want to dealing
with this because it's still a taboo
subject isn't it like one of my cousins
had developed schizophrenia had a
breakdown
and
we gave her support and we did what was
best for her but we didn't really talk
about it and that's an important part of
the problem isn't it just talking about
it and sharing because unfortunately
there are schizophrenic people
and the more if we actually discuss this
and more more honest we would be able to
deal with the situation better
yeah absolutely right i agree with you
so much and you know my on as i
mentioned my aunt had schizophrenia
my
parents uh are all psychologists you
know like psychologists and teachers and
so it's something that we talk and think
a lot about but when it came time i was
like well i'm really excited to write
about my aunt
didn't find a lot of interest among my
family members in talking about it and
it took i'm sort of slow you know on the
uptake and it took me a little bit to
figure out
kind of why nobody was
really wanting to talk about it she was
a really difficult person
schizophrenia is a really difficult
mental illness
and i think the good thing is for people
that have had that in the family is that
they know that and so there's a passage
in san francisco
that i think is a really important
passage on mental illness which is the
main character the main social worker
character is a dutch guy
named renee and i point out he looks
just like the british action hero
jason statham
you know kind of a tough guy but also
super soft you know he was actually a
nurse
and they were trying to help drug
addicts in the late 1980s and early
1990s just giving them needles and
methadone just all the helping
approaches and they realized they had to
arrest some of them they had to put
pressure on them they had to intervene
in the lives of addicts
but he told a story where
a friend of the family had a man had the
son you know just got schizophrenia you
know and part of the reason that most
people think there's some genetic origin
here is that
schizophrenia tends to show up when
you're in college or when you're
between the ages of 17 and 21 22
you know it's really suggests some sort
of
biological mechanism genetic mechanism
is being triggered it's not to say
there's no environmental role but
so
anyway this young man came had
schizophrenia
you know and the family's dealing with
it
you know with the delusions
and
renee
he says you know he goes sometimes you
do some things you're not supposed to do
you know that are off book you know
and
and so he grabbed him by the lapels
basically got him in the hospital a
couple times took him to a shelter one
time kind of muscled him
and
my staff you know my research
colleagues and i were kind of like they
were like that's pretty edgy and you
know it's because it sounds like you're
endorsing it and i'm like well let's
let's put it in context
you know people with schizophrenia that
don't get the proper treatment or care
in california they end up in prison in
these plexiglass cells by themselves
bad things happen you know plexiglas so
they can kind of wash down the walls
that get filthy
um
this person in that renee saved has his
own car has his own apartment has a job
he still sometimes has psychotic
delusions like renee said he just called
me this week and he was like there's
people staring at me through my window
and rene goes
try closing the curtains
you know and he goes okay that worked i
closed the curtain
um
that's a good outcome you know people
need to know that's a great outcome my
aunt living in a group home never
became an addict never
as far as we know you know turned to sex
work
you know smoked cigarettes and flirted
with guys all day and chatted them up
and that was it that's a good outcome
you know and so you're so i think you're
right because i think we do need to talk
about it because
you know we need to know that i think
the big lessons are
it's really hard some amount of coercion
some amount of involuntary
hospitalization is definitely the right
way to go and also is the right way to
go according to people with schizo who
have had schizophrenia
you know nobody wants to get to a
situation where the people with
schizophrenia they tell horror stories
of being restrained
anything to avoid restraints anything to
avoid
really harsh physical treatment of
people with mental illness we should try
to do and if that means sometimes you
got to kind of grab them by the lapels
and get them into the hospital that's
going to be justifiable over much worse
treatment later on
uh michael one of before we move on to
the drugs issue because obviously that
will be a big part of the conversation
the one thing that
i always find incredibly frustrating and
confusing is that these very sim not
simple but these very practical
practical that's what i was looking
these very practical problems
become politicized
why is solving a practical problem like
the fact that there are a lot of people
who don't have somewhere to live and who
are addicted to drugs or who are
mentally ill on the streets why do we
have to look at that through the lens of
conservatism or progressivism or
whatever why can't that just be a thing
that gets solved by people who
understand how that the renaissance of
the world why can't we just get a renee
in charge of it and a bunch of other
rnas to run the thing and let the people
who are professionals and experts in
that field do the best that they know to
do
and instead we seem to be listening to
french philosophers and whoever else
about how we should address this issue
right exactly
great question and that's a huge
motivation of mine for both of my books
and then the third one which is what's
going what's driving this um
you know what's what's really behind it
and so you know i mean you know the
short answer is ideology
i want to go a little further and
actually suggest that it is a religion
that it's a substitute religion and that
it engages in supernatural thinking
and also is imposing a numerality
so you know yeah i mean there's sort of
you go there's a period in the in the
late 19th century when we're you know
struggling but they're trying to you
know deal with schizophrenia there's all
sorts of terrible treatments but there's
also some more positive ones i think
they're making progress it wasn't
perfect they did start to get some new
drugs in the 50s
and we were probably on a path we could
have been on a path to really just
treating psychiatrist schizophrenics in
the way that that the dutch do which i
think is
you know i would say that's the best
available treatment it's gold standard
that's the best we know how to do is
what my my so my character renee did
it's can be kind of messy but they
basically have the best outcomes
for the people with schizophrenia
why did michelle with these guys
what do the dutch do
well that story i just told
you know is a big part of it but it's
it's a significant there's more
there's less of this kind of
you know on the one hand it's kind of
namby pamby liberal and on the other
hand it's kind of more radical left
it's not like well who can really say
who's mentally ill
it's like no like just shut up that's
stupid like
you know what i mean like we can do that
like we can actually we can have
confidence in our ability to identify
like that guy i just did an interview
with a guy
i don't know if there was underlying
mental illness or is just addiction but
he tried to told me he had the grand
unified theory of physics quantum
relativity everything asked string
theory asked him to explain to me
and
he actually forgot one of the main
branches of science he couldn't remember
he couldn't remember quantum mechanics
he what he was saying didn't make any
sense like you don't like
stop relativizing him so the people that
would relativize and go well who's to
say maybe he's no he's obviously
mentally ill
or suffering drug addiction or both
so there's some of that and then you
kind of go where does that come from
well it really came from the radical
left so sorry but it does come from this
does come from foucault so the question
is why do we listen to foucault
right like why did foucault
why was foucault instantly about an
international bestseller i mean he was
first the darling of french
mainstream news media i mean i point out
too
people always look at the 60s as radical
but really the 50s is when it starts you
know why did all the hollywood
celebrities go and try to save
a murderer and rapist from the death
penalty in california they they felt
like it was cool it was and then it
became well not just the death penalty
but really we don't think people should
be in prison you know so
there's this this is there's one idea
that kind of goes you know
progressives just go too far
and i think there's a lot of that's a
pretty good way to think about a lot of
things i think they just go too far like
i was watching this recent film on the
black panthers
and there was a moment where
it was not just the panthers but also
the latino and the white radicals and
they were like the police are are are
you know abusing people and i'm like
yeah that's terrible we gotta stop that
and then they go there should be no more
police in our neighborhoods and i was
like well well that's where you go too
far like i just saw the moment right
there like
police abuse should not happen
that's yes correct and we should fix
that to there should be no police right
like you're like that just goes too far
on the other hand
it's not just going too far it's also
there's something more much more
profound going on which is an effort to
undo these these institutions of
civilization and i think that's where
that's where you get to this trilogy i'm
working on is that it's impossible for
me not to connect
this effort to shut down mental
hospitals and psychiatric hospitals not
reform them
shut them down and empty everybody into
the streets
that looked
just the way in which that occurred the
people involved the timing is the it is
identical to kind of shutting down
nuclear power plants
not wanting to build nuclear power
plants in the 1960s
there's a kind of
dogmatism behind it there's a kind of
irrationality
there's a sense in which it's actually
it's not about the nuclear plants or the
mental hospitals it's actually they want
to remake society in a utopian way and
they view these institutions which are
really civilizing institutions they're
actually liberal institutions they're
actually progressive institutions
they they view them as as barriers to
creating an alternative society and so
there is a kind of it's not just going
too far there's a specific group of
people
what we call the radical left and really
i believe is a kind of religious
movement that is looking to tear down
these institutions because they have a
really spiritual supernatural view of
what should replace them
no that is obviously i think anyone who
watches our channel will appreciate that
that perspective on it and it's one that
i share wholeheartedly
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns
have rock-solid network infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydnest.com forward
slash triggered and use our promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get fifty percent off with the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
the question i am still trying to work
out for myself mike and this is perhaps
where you can help with your background
being from that part of the political
spectrum is
why
let me put it simply why do we give a
[ __ ] what these crazy utopians say and
what they want why does government
listen to these people why are they
seemingly running a lot of the major
institutions the education system why do
we give them the opportunity to do this
as a society
right well i think there's sort of so
then you kind of go okay so let's assume
that there's only really a radical
minority a radical left minority that
wants to truly tear down the
institutions which i believe and agree
with if you pull if you take surveys
public opinion surveys and you were
asked that question it would be a very
small minority
i mean maybe five percent maybe maybe
more now um most people in fact i did i
did poll people by the way i did surveys
of the public um vast majority of people
are on board with the kind of program
that i'm describing 70 to 80 majority
so then what's going on well look i mean
obviously a big part of this is just
appealing to the heartstrings
you know and that's involved
misinformation so the radical left which
knows very well that the people on the
street are addicted to hard drugs
they you know they i don't know if they
are explicit about it but they they
they're using them to advocate for
housing for subsidized housing they kind
of wave away the addiction as a result
of poverty
rather than the cause of it
and then they they kind of then just
tried to trick everybody you know and
it's kind of like you know i'm not some
of them are not even consciously doing
it but it's kind of like
oh don't you care about this poor person
don't we just want to help them it's
just that you know it's simple and most
people don't think about this stuff
and and it's just at the level of
charity
and so it's sort of masking
a much more radical agenda as charity
and then charity appeals to basically
everybody i mean we probably said what i
call weaponized empathy michael
weaponized empathy that's what it is i
call it pathological altruism
yeah yeah but there's definitely yeah
and there's something
at its worst it's something almost
sociopathic about it you know there's
something there's dark what we call the
dark triad which is sociopathy
narcissism and machiavellianism
on the part of the of the real leaders
of this movement that really are doing
this stuff
to manipulate people
and then i think there's a and then i
have a
so that's kind of your average liberal
type person there are those
conservatives
who
i think have had some part of this
correct which is that you can't just
give things to people without asking for
anything in return that's something that
i think the right the political right
has been saying
for decades
so then the question is why hasn't that
succeeded politically and in fact why
has it in some ways lost power over the
last 30 years and to some extent i think
there's reasons that have nothing to do
with the political right
just we're all much more coddled and
spoiled and and liberal and privileged
and there's just not a lot of
sympathy for the more stoic harder
approach to life
i think another part of it though is
that the right has
been
unwilling to talk about
the need for things like universal
psychiatric care
and even has just been uncomfortable
with psychology and psychiatry in
general
i'm not totally sure i got to the bottom
of it but
you know when you look at the
deinstitutionalization of the
psychiatric hospitals both in britain
and the united states
it's being pushed by the radical left
but
the kind of liberals then were like yeah
it's got to be right because it's
because everyone's intentions are good
and then conservatives kind of went
along with it for cost-saving measures
and also out of discomfort with
psychiatry
now i think that's then changed in the
netherlands renee
my character from the netherlands and
his wife dilon who by the way you know
could be prime minister one day she's a
very successful politician
they are part of a center-right
political party that actually formed in
part in backlash to the open street uh
the uh
the open drug scenes
in amsterdam in the late 80s and early
1990s
so i guess i i would say i have part of
the reason i'm so obsessed with the
netherlands because i also love them on
the environments and energy you know
they live below sea level and prove that
sea level rise is not the end of the
world
part of the reason i love the dutch so
much is i do think they're a bit ahead
of us and so my hope is that there would
be some sort of
center right although i think it could
possibly sit on the center left but
maybe more difficultly
center-right political formation
that would have majority power and
governing power
in the united states and other western
countries because the dutch have shown
that that sort of political formation
is not only viable but then can actually
fix the problem
michael before we move on to the drugs
the last question i want to ask you is
this we've been talking about you know
the religious progressivism and
conservative
isn't there also just a very human
element to this which is
we don't want to admit to ourselves that
just some people are always going to
need to be looked after some people are
never going to get better some people
are always going to be vulnerable and
that is just the way it is and that
isn't something that we want to accept
i actually oh i was i agreed with
everything you're about to say until the
very last thing you said i think that
that is what you said
well you said that there's just some
people that are gonna have to be taken
care of that are just if we're honest
calling wards of the state
to use an ugly expression but i think a
honest one
that's i find that i found that to be
the place of the most common ground
including from dissident radical left
folks
i actually quote a few of them in the
book there's so
and in fact on on twitter there's some
marxists and socialist critics
of liberalism there are people that talk
they use the they talk all they talk a
lot of trash about the so-called
professional managerial class
um you know sort of the spiked types of
you know former lefties or lefties where
they have a more class-based view also
christopher lash is an important thinker
in this tradition
but um they kind of go this is bonkers
this is not you know they're like
basically they would say something like
socialists
you know don't think it's it's humane to
leave schizophrenics on the street like
there's nothing about marx or socialism
that would have you leave people with
schizophrenia on the streets
at the same time i find a number i mean
i quote conservatives at the end of san
francisco saying
look
we just know that conservatives
intelligent conservatives know you
there's just a set of people you have to
take care of
so in some ways i go i lay i like that
as a um
a starting place for some agreement and
that's why we call it cal psych i mean
you start with people that look
everybody agrees people have
schizophrenia i mean
mishofiko is dead and and i'm sorry but
there's just a handful a tiny handful of
people that are gonna deny
that somebody with schizophrenia has
schizophrenia or some serious mental
illness
and then you can kind of build from
there then you i think you're dealing
with people with with
you know non-serious mental illness
including people suffering from drug
addiction
and then there's some effort to make
them independent but you know honestly
even with some of those so-called awards
of the state or people schizophrenia
some of them can work
you know i mean and so and so i think
it's also a way to say
we're never going to give up on anybody
you know we're always going to be trying
to help people to live their best
possible selves and to be
you know i think embracing
i think into the center right
if that's what this is
a more psychologically aware a more a
more pro-psychiatry a more psychiatry
positive outlook
michael as you're talking i just can't
help this feeling like
i i know i've asked you this question
before i'm going to try again
why is it about politics this is not an
issue that should be about i don't i
don't care if the solution look i'm not
on the radical left i'm not on the right
either but let's say that the people i
oppose the most are the two extremes the
radical left and the far right i don't
care if the solution to this problem if
the radical left come up with a good
solution to this issue i will happily
back it if the right do i will happily
back it i care about solving the problem
and to me it seems just ridiculous that
we go oh but conservatives and you know
why why can't we just leave this to
people who actually know what they're
doing
have we lost the ability to do that
entirely
sure feels like that i mean
so um yes on the one hand obviously we
have otherwise it wouldn't the situation
wouldn't be so bad we wouldn't have a
hundred thousand deaths last year from
this issue in the united states and many
deaths in britain and scotland too and
in europe not as bad but
obviously it's something that we have
and you know you're right in the sense
that there is a kind of marriage of left
and right in the sense that the left is
correct you need universal psychiatric
care that's something the left has been
saying for a really long time they go
further and say you need universal
health care i tend to agree
um you need that
the right has been saying that you have
to have obligations with your
rights
and there should be some individual
responsibility that's obviously correct
uh i think you're gonna even have a hard
time getting many people on the left to
disagree with that so this is uh that's
that's it i mean you kind of go those
are that's it it's just carrots and
sticks
right each one of those has been owned
by left and right but you need both of
them
i will say though that while i think
that's the right solution
i don't think it's ac it wouldn't be
accurate to describe i mean the book is
still called why progressives ruin
cities because
it wasn't an equal role played by
conservatives and progressives and so i
think when i go all the way to the
bottom to answer your question
how did something that should be dealt
with
as a medical issue as it's almost a
technical question or a scientific
question how did it get politicized it's
it's really the radical left that was
doing that it wasn't conservatives in
part because conservatives had their own
religion or have their own religion
actually working on a piece called
you know the reason
you know basically explain the reason
that that the radical left is doing this
is because they're looking for a new god
and so my my underlying argument is that
the death what frederick nietzsche
called the death of god which
sociologists call secularization which
is basically the broad the increasing
disbelief and traditional religion in
afterlife heaven or reincarnation or an
all-powerful
all-seeing god the growing disbelief in
that and the belief that our lives have
no intrinsic meaning that we don't have
a soul that there's no real reason or
purpose for us to be here
that as that
that alternative that so-called
atheistic or secular view has grown it's
increased anxiety and that part of the
purpose of religion and what religion
does is it provides us with comfort and
and security
and without that um
most people including people who think
that they're secular will construct an
alternative religion
and they've done that
with that's what woke-ism is
complete with an apocalyptic view of
climate change a supernatural view of
race
you know i always point out why is it
that if i became a woman if i declare
myself a woman tomorrow
i would be applauded by progressives but
if i came out as african-american i
would be demonized and ostracized
the only explanation for that arbitrary
you know uh identity identity
categorization is a supernatural view
you know both of gender and of race
actually
so this is we're dealing with a you know
where as my friend john mcwhorter points
out his new book woke racism you know
it's like we're witnessing the emergence
of a new pagan religion
in the same way that the you know romans
witnessed the birth of christianity
i don't think it can survive in the
sense that it's it's destroys
civilization if you if you are basically
saying
that we should not enforce the laws
equally which is what woke religion is
saying which is what the radical left is
saying which is what they're doing which
is why we have
you know 200 000 people in the streets
more addicted to hard drugs
it it's it creates too many
contradictions it creates too many
problems so
i do kind of go i mean i've been saying
for like three years i'm like it can't
get any worse and then it gets worse
i i do believe particularly because my
environmental work shows it too you know
these trends are non-linear
you know pollution does go down um
uh societies do respond to drug crises
um
society's institutions do change
you know like we're the west god damn it
we're liberal and we're democratic and
our institutions fix themselves but
we're definitely in the midst
of an ethical
change i believe that's going on right
now as we speak around politics around
what left and right even mean
and around what what are the big issues
of the day and what we need to be
worried about and how to solve them
and
one of the issues that we're talking
about a lot is the the decriminalization
of drugs particularly of marijuana in
order to one of the things
in order to solve this problem is that
what we need to do michael we need to
decriminalize drugs and these people are
addicted to hard drugs whether it be
fentanyl heroin whatever it may be
they need the proper help given to them
yeah so yeah i mean in terms of i think
it all depends as you might imagine on
what we mean by decriminalization
so when i stopped doing this i i when i
was doing this work in the late 90s and
i got out of it around 2000
my understanding was that
there would be decriminalization
but addicts
particularly ones who were breaking the
laws
would be
would be
mandated rehabilitation
that didn't happen we just did the
decriminalization part without mandating
rehabilitate without mandating rehab
or even enforcing the laws
when addicts break the law and they
break the law like every day
so
yes
if you have consequences for behavioral
disorders
decriminalization can work now
decriminalization
doesn't mean there's no consequences it
just means that it's not a felony
to be using drugs
there are benefits to that because it
does mean that people can get help
without fearing prison
but if you don't have the mandatory
rehab then it's not going to work so i
actually went and because one of the
things you hear
people suddenly say well if we just had
more if we had decriminalization then
there'd be less addiction
not at all you could have a lot more
you know people when drugs become
cheaper and more available addiction
goes up i mean that's part of how we had
the crack epidemic meth i mean part of
why we have a drug problem is that drugs
have become much cheaper and more
available
in part just through supply chain
efficiencies you know drug dealers
are really good at bringing drugs into
different countries really amazing and
clearly have outpaced law enforcement
every step of the way
i i personally that's one issue where i
remain
i hold a continue to have a left of
center view which is that i just don't
think you can stop the drugs from coming
in it's too easy
to get drugs into countries especially
when they're so concentrated
so that's why i tend to focus on
dealing with
behavioral disorders of addicts in
public
i just don't think there's much stomach
i don't have it i don't think my fellow
citizens have it of arresting addicts
who want to even smoke fentanyl in the
privacy of their own homes
i think it's nuts
i don't think you should
i think it should be stigmatized
but i don't think it should be a law
enforcement priority
on the other hand if your addiction is
leading you to break the law defecate in
public camp in public steal
commit crimes then you should be
arrested
and you should be given the choice of
prison or rehab
and michael one of the things that i
think a lot of people
haven't quite got a grasp of certainly
here in the uk
and perhaps much around the world is
what the extent to which this lack of
enforcement of the law
uh and the decriminalization of certain
disruptive behavior has occurred in
cities like los angeles and san
francisco to the point where correct me
if i'm wrong but i'm seeing reports of
the bubonic plague making a comeback in
certain quarters because of the human
feces that are everywhere you've got uh
decriminalization of theft so if you
walk into a store
in california in certain places and you
steal uh things from that store if it's
under like a thousand dollars or nine
hundred dollars you don't get prosecuted
for that uh
etc etc i mean this sounds to me frozen
outside and again please correct me if
i'm wrong i really genuinely hope it's
not as bad
the this is like the breakdown of
society happening on a localized scale
on certain pockets and certain streets
in in a major western city
it's it's the breakdown of the city it's
the breakdown of the civilization it's
one of the many ways in which
civilization is western civilization is
falling apart
the trend that was accelerated by kovid
i mean basically every important
institution
is under attack
we have 400 fewer police officers in san
francisco than we need for the minimum
we have the spectacular crimes going on
they've boarded up all of the luxury i
mean not just luxury but also the
mid-range
uh shops in union square which is the
kind of world-famous shopping center of
san francisco you know it's where the
ice skating rink is and it's the
romantic
christmas macy's christmas tree part of
san francisco
so yeah it's uh you know that we used to
have these you know
slum neighborhoods or the ghetto where
there would be open drug use
and the city had a policy of containment
just trying to contain all of the
dysfunction in a single neighborhood
basically what's happened i mean the
reason i had i have a book out on this
issue is because they
were no longer able to contain the
problem in a few neighborhoods and it
just spreads all over the city
you know yeah human feces everywhere
they've decided to solve it not by
you know
requiring people to sleep indoors and
use the bathrooms and doors but actually
just having either porta potties and
also just doing a lot of street cleaning
so the problem is that san francisco is
so wealthy it just ends up paying more
and more money for different services we
spend about a hundred thousand dollars
per homeless person
um to let them sleep in tents on the
street
wow so you know it's uh it's an amazing
situation um but yeah i view
civilization as under attack it sounds
very melodramatic i know but
the electrical our energy systems are uh
you know we're basically in a global
energy crisis in part because there's a
big effort to move away from reliable
energy to unreliable energy
our universities no longer teach what
you would consider a liberal arts
education they teach
really something more like victim
ideology or woke ideology
we our psychiatric hospitals are not
allowed to function um our police
departments are under attack and the
police are leaving
because they don't want to work in
conditions of hara of ongoing harassment
from radical left activists who throw
feces and urine at them and tell them
and call them fascists and sue them and
try to get them
uh to uh to commit violence so that
um they can attack the police some more
um
it's not great guys
uh
makes for
interesting makes for interesting
journalism
i mean i find myself writing stories now
about crime
and i never
was interested in crime but now crime i
think is like the most interesting one
of the most interesting subjects
in american life right now
um
that's a bad
that shows that things are in a bad way
here
you what you have just said michael
isn't a society falling apart
the picture that you've just painted is
a society that's failed
to me that is a society that has reached
crisis point
and if something isn't done soon
it's over isn't it if that's the case
looks bad
i mean
non-linear trends faith and you know
faith in something
yeah you know i mean um
you know i i find so i laugh at like the
thing i'm about to say but i mean um
because i'm i do come from the left but
i mean a friend of mine was like
describing margaret thatcher and how she
came to power against the complete
shutdowns
you know by the coal miners and by i
think the garbage unions and you know
new york had a big garbage strike in the
70s and
you know everybody says everybody's
talking about and i agree you're like it
is just like the 70s like are we headed
for stagflation next
which is like a complete vacuum of
political leadership
particularly on the left
but even a significant amount of
confusion
on the right in some places although
some of that may be changing
you know i i think that the moment is
clearly ripe for some political
leadership i mean i wrote the book with
the hope that somebody would seize that
mantle but
you know i do think you need something
that is not
what left and right have traditionally
been to articulate a solution to this
crisis
that makes a lot of sense i mean i i
think as you suggested what you need is
someone who can bring people together
around that 70 80 percent of people who
are who are not insane on either extreme
um and that's generally the people that
tend to win elections historically and
make big progress in society
uh you know whatever you think of tony
blair or margaret thatcher they
commanded the respect of the majority of
the society at the time because they
delivered big
pro whatever your definition of the word
progress is they delivered big positive
change in society that made made
people's lives better so you're right
it's right but the one thing that i
always admire very much about the
american system michael is that
uh you have 50 states
and
each state has the ability to do things
the way it wants and what you've seen in
california in particular is a lot of
people who are creative who are
successful who don't want to live in
human feces they just took their
business and went elsewhere do you think
some of those market forces will will
help to drive like you know when
california runs out of money because
there's nobody generating
you know tax revenue there
do you think that will be the sort of
thing that pushes this agenda forward or
do you think the the progressives are so
obsessed with the ideological side of
this that they genuinely don't care
about the consequences
i yeah i mean
i mean i agree with what you said i mean
i think there's going to be a political
response
it'll have to be a political response
there is a political response going on
you know you saw there's a big upset
election in virginia virginia
you know important state in the united
states
should have been won by the democrat won
by the republican
very disciplined person very disciplined
campaign
they figured out
you know i mean i mean that in contrast
to donald trump i mean this is a guy
that got elected governor of virginia
who
really changed who i mean really
presented himself as he needed to do in
a really disciplined way and and then
won a pretty decisive victory and then
republicans almost went in new jersey
something like that is going to happen a
lot more
and
you know i do think the right is
is going to
devour is divided over trump
and the left is now has a vacuum of
leadership at the very top right i mean
that neither the pre and not only i mean
it's really interesting
neither our president or our vice
president is really
leading
in the sense of even being the leader of
their own party if there's a leader of
the democratic party now it's nancy
pelosi
who runs you know one of the houses of
congress so
um
i think we're in a really interesting
vacuum of leadership now i do think that
you know nature abhors a vacuum so there
will be
that vacuum will be occupied by new
leaders and so in some ways i do think
we're headed for a really interesting
period
you know i think we're definitely in the
post neoliberal
you know we're in the post clintonian
post blarion
period and it does seem like it's things
are going to shift back more to the
political right
you know um i mean even the united
states it's interesting because even
before the trouble with the current
president
you know there's all these demographic
trends that showed that really
republicans were likely to kind of make
rich you know regain and probably
maintain control of the senate long term
they have control over the supreme court
um but now just because the vacuum of
leadership on the left it does seem like
there's an opportunity for for
leadership on the right if it's of
course not blocked by by trump
so anyway i don't mean to get into the
current events too much because no no no
that's interesting i was actually going
to ask you
when you talk about the situation on the
right
with donald trump i take it your
interpretation is that he's too
incendiary and characters like him
cannot unite a majority of the country
around
in the sort of thatcher stroke blair
kind of way talking in uk
was that is that broadly your position
yeah absolutely i mean i view trump as a
transitional figure as a uh as chaos
as super clown energy
um
maybe coyote i mean you know like if you
kind of mythologically look at it which
sometimes helps you know to get away
from the kind of day-to-day he's like
the joker you know i mean one thing you
have to remember about trump is he's
really funny actually um
liberals don't like it and they don't
get it um
but he's funny and um
um i mean i don't like all of it some of
i think some of it i think is funny but
but some of it's just kind of stupid but
he's a clown
so he's not reagan
right um
i can't figure out
historical parallels to him
in politics you know um
maybe bolsonaro currently in brazil you
know um
but you know he's not like you know
people are always he's a strong man
strong men are really disciplined you
know strong men especially if they're
from the military these are disciplined
people
he's much more chaotic you know much
more like hugo chavez or something yeah
where
they're a temporary sort of just burst
of chaos and clown fire energy and
everything burns and then kind of what's
left remaining is
okay republicans are
you know after like after all that
you're like okay republicans
are mostly against invading other
countries
in favor of keeping medicare and social
security which are the entitlements um
they're not anti-gay anymore
and it's a nationalist party like you
kind of go that's kind of what gets left
over after you remove trump from the
equation
but the problem with trump is that if he
gets you know if he gets the nomination
or if he became president again
it's just it's almost like you couldn't
do any of the agenda because there's
just too much he's too
chaotic and of course he'll be much
older
he's too chaotic and his opponents
there would be no one for him to kind of
work with on the other side whereas if
you got more of a reagan type figure
who was more disciplined implementing if
someone more like the virginia mate the
governor of virginia the recent newly
elected
republican governor of virginia you
could see him finding some compromises
with democrats
and really forcing the democrats to make
some compromises because of his
political popularity and strength
michael do you think we're going to see
a resurgence of populism
particularly in america with all with
all the with all the problems that
you've just detailed
well i mentioned i one of the first
things i saw of you guys was an
incredible conversation you had with
this scholar on the rise of populism
and nationalism matt goodwin yeah um
where he really i think convincingly
shows that we're we're in a populist uh
period
um
i think it got accelerated by kovid
and and the pandemic i think we're going
to see much more of it after the
pandemic i think we are seeing more of
it i mean just the case go back to the
case of the virginia guy
he ran
basically saying stop letting the
elitist teachers
teach our kids wacky racist stuff
um
and parents have a right
parents staying up for parents that's a
very populist thing right so
for sure it's happening it's going to
happen a ton more i think
and that's going to bring its own set of
challenges and chaos
um could be positive
uh could be very negative
uh it could be very positive to be very
negative i mean that's like
you know that's the moment that we're in
though right
yeah it is and
given from you know we've spoken to
people who are close to to the big don
uh he is he's definitely going to run
again it looks like
uh
and you talk about people are going to
have an a populist appetite i mean that
is a [ __ ] nightmare waiting to happen
all together if you ask me because you
bring that together and look you know
people you you mentioned donald trump
being the strong man i didn't feel that
i didn't see any authoritarianism out of
his presidency you might have
you could argue there was you know a
lack of focus there was incompetence
there was an inability to work with
across the aisle all of those things i
think are true but to me the biggest
thing was actually just the hysteria
from
the the establishment in respect of him
i actually personally felt that
the bulk of the
the things that i might criticize donald
trump for was not actually what he did
but just simply the fact that he
elicited such a visceral
reaction
in in a portion of society that is
influential and that's not even
necessarily a criticism of him directly
i would say but anyway what you're
predicting sounds to me like we're in
for some absolute chaos coming going
forward
yeah you're scaring me constantine well
you're scaring me you're the one that
said it
well yeah i mean let's let's okay so
then that means that we should take a
really hard look at some of the positive
trends
right you know so
so yeah i mean i i i i wrote i'm writing
these books for
an intellectual movement that i wanted
to be a part of and support
and after i got done writing them
there's no more that movement no longer
exists which was the intellectual dark
web
of which you guys are clearly uh members
and i don't even care if you agree
because i just go europe idw i say so um
but i mentioned this to joe rogan and he
was what's that
i said we've been so conscripted into it
yes
thank you yeah you're in it um
and joe was like
no like that's a stupid word that's a
stupid name and i was like okay maybe
but like
it's like you kind of go stupid but yet
we all know who's in it
like
we all like you can kind of go you can
kind of go there's like and i was even
drawing these like
like i was like okay there's like the
pro-vaxxer idw types and then there's
the anti-vaxx idw types and it basically
overlaps with who likes trump and who
doesn't
you know and it's like is it ew left and
right or is it like relationship to
government but you kind of go you know
okay and then there's some people that
don't like each other that are in it
that's part of it
right but but nonetheless i go there's
something clearly going on that's that's
that i think is
intellectual
you know that is like a salon that's
podcasts that's that's long
that's a what uh daniel kahneman calls
slow thinking
[Music]
it's uh it's
you know it's not fox news you know
there might be parts of tucker carlson
that are idw
but it's not it's long form it's podcast
it's thoughtful
it has a kind of um
it's totally fine with gays and lesbians
and frankly with trans people um but it
will push back against trans crazy trans
activists and crazy
you know it believes in climate change
it thinks climate change is a concern we
should do something about it but it's
anti-apocalyptic
it's pushing back against the new
religion it's pushing back against the
new dogmatism
um
i think it's very serious i think it's a
very significant group of people it's
you know it's um
you all everyone knows who it is it's
barry weiss it's nellie bowles it's joe
rogan it's
it's um
uh jordan peterson it's
brett
brett and heather it's claire layman and
colette even though those two those guys
hate each other right now because
they're fighting about kovid and part of
me goes you know
kovid's it's not going to go away in
fact it's going to become endemic it is
becoming endemic um
but as an issue of debate it's going to
become a lot smaller and afterwards
there's still going to be the idw and
heather and claire will become friends
again or maybe not but but they'll still
be in the idw and there's still a kind
of so i kind of go there's that is real
and as soon as you say as soon as you
describe who's in it and the thinking
there
you can kind of go
well it may not be mainstream it may not
be the center of the overton window
right now but it's driving this debate
it's actually leading the conversation
the new york times is describing you
know i think chris ruffo is this really
interesting person
who i've gotten to know but he's been
basically single-handedly taking taking
down critical race there in the united
states
um you know he identifies at this point
as republican and conservative
um
but he's just clearly not like your
dad's
republican right and so or what about a
guy like glenn greenwald you know like
sometimes i read glenn greenwald i'm
like he hasn't changed anything in his
view
like his views are identical to what
they were when i was reading him after 9
11.
like i can't figure out anything he's
changed his mind on
still an anti-imperialist
socialist as far as i can tell
um
but yet you kind of go oh it's probably
something that has changed you know like
i think there's something happening
where
us on the idw side of things or on the
kind of idw left go
hey
i don't think crime is progressive or
liberal
it seems like all the victims are like
poor
african-american
you know like or you know disadvantaged
people like
crime is bad
and then you're kind of like
well that's a pretty mainstream view
that crime is bad and and actually the
idea that crime is not bad is um
completely marginal and so you go well
idw folks
are articulating i think a new
mainstream view
it's a practical view it's pragmatic you
know joe rogan's not proselytizing
ivermectin but he took it
you know and you kind of go there's some
folks in this movement that you kind of
go you're taking some kind of you sound
kind of dogmatic dude
and probably i sound that way to people
on things like nuclear power but
you kind of go yeah ivermectin may not
be the right solution
vaccines i think are great i'm a big
proponent of vaccines but i also kind of
go
how much
more pressure are we going to put on
members of our society to get it you
know um and so you get to some kind of
prac i think you were sort of saying
constantine like
there's a practicalness here in the idw
i think the best of the idw that we want
to hold on to
um and a kind of populism too
um
yeah michael you know that i think i
want to hold on so i go that has that's
right when i look for hope i go that's
where i find the hope it's in this new
media idw
cluster the one thing i hope we can
retain now that you've you've
conscripted us into that you're the
first person to ever suggest that we are
in 90w and i i gratefully accept uh that
with all the consequences that it brings
but
like
the one thing that i think is very
important as a new member of the iew is
tolerance of people with different views
that's the one thing that will break it
if it's not maintained and i think covet
is rapidly stress testing that sense
that look i i i love brett and heather i
consider them friends i'm honored that
they consider us friends i think they're
wonderful people having listened to the
stuff
you know on balance i'm not sure based
on what i've read and the people i've
spoken with i'm not convinced that
ivamekton
is the answer to this issue i like joe i
think he's really cool as well
if i got coveted i wouldn't take over
mech to myself but i i'm okay with joe
taking it i think the fact that brett
thinks it's a good idea well that's up
to him you know like there's a there's a
respect for
difference of opinion i mean to me that
is that used to be the sign of
intelligent people that they're able to
disagree about important things and
retain friendships and retain mutual
respect
and that's my only hope is that we don't
lose that in this process and i do see
one or two people uh straying into into
territory which i do think is unhelpful
in that respect
yeah i agree and it's and so you know
and you kind of go
it might be that look because of course
if idw is just we're a bunch of people
that are open-minded
then it's not really like a thing you
know what i mean then it's just it's
just it's just a bunch of nice people
that have podcasts and that's fine um
and part of me was just more ambitious
in the sense that you know i kind of was
like
i was like here's what i think the idw
should be
you know in both apocalypse never and in
san francisco like i'm
gonna have the argument i mean i'm kind
of like well i don't know whatever i'm
not sure what it would mean to not be
tolerant but certainly i'll have the
debate or argument with anybody
um about the ideas in the book but for
me i think the
potential of something like the idw is
to have
a view of these things and that doesn't
mean that you're like kicking people out
of the cool kids club because they are
ivermectin users
but it would be kind of more like yeah
there's kind of a recognizably iedw
take on that
and that may not be possible
and if it's not that's totally fine just
you know happy to be
you know having these conversations but
it does feel to me like idw
had the potential to be something like
the
um i mean the classic intellectual
movement of late was the was really the
neocons that came out of the out of the
radical left where there was this really
influential movement the neocons that
gave rise to reagan and thatcher and
that there was needing to be something
something like that again
to kind of revive
moribund a morriband
call it center right politics for lack
of a better
descriptor but something that was not
was not exactly trumpy trumpy but
appreciated some of trump's
interventions
in the culture not socialist but maybe
appreciated some things that bernie
sanders was saying
and the need for things like universal
healthcare universal psychiatry that
kind of thing and that there would be
something at the end of it that was like
a recognizable agenda that was my that's
part of my ambition and maybe
it may not be something that we can
realize but for me i kind of go
i kind of have some faith that once i
get everybody in the idw to read my
books
will get you all to agree that that's
the right idw agenda
fantastic michael i suppose on that
happy note we're gonna we're gonna ask
you a couple of questions for our locals
uh for our members only in the second
but before we do that we've got one more
question for you as always which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
um
do we all don't we all need a spiritual
don't we all need a spirituality
even if you think you don't
and then if you don't have one aren't
you going to create one aren't you
really going to create one secretly that
you're unaware of and unconscious to and
it's going to do bad things to you
that's like is that a question that's
what i want to talk about is like are
humans just is this like
like you need food you need water you
need love you need work you need
meaningful work but don't you kind of
need
a sense of spirituality too
that's what i think we should talk about
is this the point michael you're gonna
bring the crystals out
exactly exactly the incense is burning
guys
[Laughter]
welcome to california yeah michael
launches into a massive thing about how
you find jesus yeah michael it's been an
absolute pleasure chatting with you uh
we are going to ask you a couple of
questions for our locals but in the
meantime uh the book is san francisco i
really recommend everybody get it uh
where else can people find you online
and follow along with what you're doing
thank you yeah uh people can find the
books on amazon san francisco and
apocalypse never
i'm on twitter a lot my handle is
shellenberger and then my initials md
i'm not a medical doctor those are my
initials
um but i'm on twitter it's a great place
to find me on facebook my email is
michael schallenberger gmail.com and i i
generally respond to every
substantive email so i love to hear from
people
fantastic
thank you very much michael guys
yeah it's been an absolute pleasure guys
if you've enjoyed this interview and why
wouldn't you it's been absolutely
brilliant uh please remember they always
go out wednesday sunday 7 p.m uk time 2
p.m eastern standard and we also do raw
shows which are on thursday friday
saturday at the exact same time plus if
you like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below